les agriculteurs yvelinois de nouveau
mobilisés en ce lundi 29 janvier 2024
vous le voyez dernièr mois le blocage de
la 13 au niveau du pH de bûchelet se
prépare dans quelques minutes les
agriculteurs vont s'insérer sur la 13 on
est juste avant la sortie Mantel jolie
centre ils vont s'insérer sur la 13 et
fermer au niveau de la sortie
mantelaville maganville laissant
bloquant ainsi le péage de la 1 au
niveau de bûchelet et la sortie aussi
bûchelet centre commercial et ils iront
ensuite bloquer le sens province Paris
donc la 13 sera fermée au niveau du
péage de bûchelet dans les deux cens de
circulation par les agriculteurs
ivlinois qui sont de nouveau mobilisés
aujourd'hui il est 14h30 et ça y est le
blocage de la 13 dans les de cens de
circulation est effectif ici un
agriculteur est en train de déposer des
bottes de paille pour bloquer l'accès
dans le sens Paris province au total 80
véhicules sont mobilisés ici sur le page
de bûchelet des agriculteurs qui
viennent du pays oudané de mant-elajolie
de Mont-Fort lamorie voilà les
agriculteurs ivinois mobilisé et qui
maintiennent la pression sur le
gouvernement il y avait 120 propositions
qui ont été revend enfin qui ont été
recueillies par la fnsr sur les 120 il y
en a 10 qui ont été abordés en fait par
les par les par le par Gabriel Atal
vendredi donc on n retrouve pas nos
comptes hein c'est il a abordé quelques
sujets en fait qui concernne la majorité
des agriculteurs qui bloquaient
notamment le GNR par contre surt le
reste de nos revendications rien n'a été
rien n'a été abordé rien n'été entendu
c'est pas normal que on ait des
interdictions entre même pays d'Europe
c'estd nous on est dans l'Europe on veut
pas sortir de l'Europe mais de l'autre
côté on doit pouvoir produire la même
qualité et la même chose que les autres
pays Européens on nous parle de
souveraineté alimentaire mais mais mais
si on continue comme ça il y a 10 ans on
était 500000 agriculteurs aujourd'hui on
est 300000 dans 10 ans on sera plus que
200000 et et l'hémorragie va se faire
comme dans la cidérurgie et le textile
tout tout doucement sans en silence ça
ça se Meur gentiment et à la fin bah on
aura perdu notre souveraineté
alimentaire comme on a perdu pour le
textile ouou
l'acier les agriculteurs sont en train
de se mobiliser pour occuper la 13 24h
sur 24 pendant plusieurs jours
d'ailleurs il sont bien organisés
puisque ils ont mis en place un barbecue
plusieurs tentes avec un téléviseur des
dortoirs ou encore le foot truck pour
s'alimenté derrière moi alors qu'en
pensent les usagers de la 13 on les
écoute on est avec eux à à 100 % quoi on
a pas le choix nous aussi he il faut il
faut suivre quoi moi je suis solidaire
je comprends le je comprends leur
mouvement c'est tout c'est tout qui qui
va pas en fait il y a pas que les
paysans hein blocage c'est embêtant mais
bon après il y a un ralbol quoi il y a
un rbol total donc c'est bien que ça
bouge quand même bah je peux pas aller
au travail je suis obligé de sortir
voilà ouais je comprends ouais je
comprends je comprends très bien ce
qu'ils disent il y a pas de souci les
agriculteurs vont rester mobilisés ici
sur la 13 pendant 4 jours ils ont fermé
et bien un tronçon de 1000 m entre la
sortie Magnanville et l'entrée sur la
1ise à Magnanville direction la province
le péage est encore accessible pour
aller vers la province mais les
agriculteurs du département de l'UR ont
fermé au niveau de Vernon en revanche
dans le sens province Paris le pH de
bûchelet est fermé et les usagers que
vous voyez sur le côté ici et bien
rentrent à bchel mais sont contraints de
sortir à
maganville